welcome back to new rock stars I'm
Jessica Clemens and I'll be breaking
down Paramount pitcher newest trailer
for a quiet place day one yes it is
indeed scary season in the summer this
is the prequel to a quiet place and a
quiet place too in those movies we watch
the Abbot family survival with a baby no
less this prequel will follow Sam Lupo
nong's character on the first day the
creatures landed on Earth she's one of a
million people scrambling in New York
and what a horrible place to be when
aliens with hypers sensitive hearing
attack that's like being in Six Flags
and before we get into it a reminder to
go check out our latest merch over at
nerd riot. shop right now you can grab
our Multiverse tour shirt to celebrate
the many eras of Deadpool grabbing a
piece of merch From Nerd riot. shop is a
great way to support our Channel and all
the awesome work we do here at new rock
stars for you now sh let's get into a
quiet place John cinski wrote and
directed the first two movies this movie
he wrote but directed by Michael soski
who directed Pig if you saw Pig this man
went to incredible lengths to save his
pet pig literally did everything it took
to rescue that pig and along the way he
meets people from his past that either
help interrupt his journey the essence
is already strung together in this movie
about a woman with her cat creating
bonds with people on her journey to
survive all to say I think Michael can
really cook with this movie we open with
the footage of John krinski from the
first movie listening to a radio for the
signal Lee was always sending out those
SOS it says day 471 then ticks to day
472 and shows us the corresponding
footage to their corresponding days from
the movies the timeline for a quiet
place is weird and always up for debate
in the first movie we saw Lee's
whiteboard of chaos and newspaper
clippings many of the date say November
2018 but then B died 3 months into the
attack in 2020 so like it doesn't really
add up also if everything was destroyed
in the first few days how are people
just printing newspapers you think they
just run away or you know spray paint
stuff spray paint messages don't print
press I'm sure all of it was with the
belief of making only one like John
krinsky mentioned before with The
Hollywood Reporter which in my opinion
is fine I don't care about the
theoretics of the timeline as much as I
care about the story and stress I get in
my chair every time that baby cries in
this trailer though we see day one in
New York we open with this day in the
second movie about the Abbott family
they live in a very small town outside
of New York it was during the baseball
game when the aliens landed we didn't
know where the aliens came from and I
assumed it was just from space because
aliens usually come from space in
thriller movies like this and John krisy
in an interview mentioned how in his
mind they came from another planet that
was already destroyed I'm assuming they
landed in spring since they're playing
basball but it looks like in this
trailer it's chilly by the look of the
New Yorker wardrobe so this might be a
slip up or it's early March late
February I don't really know New York
weather like that in the trailer the
ticker counts up from day 472 to 476 and
they showcase corresponding scenes to
emotional scenes that could Curt the
first and second movie then the ticker
jumps from day 477 to 407 332 118
eventually landing on one we shot
through those dates but between day 1
and 472 A lot happened on day 89 the
world is basically wiped out this is the
day that b is killed by that one
creature after playing with that toy on
the train tracks so this is almost 3
months into the attack in the trailer
the damage is done on the first day
immediately so how Barren the world is
by day 89 makes sense because everyone
assimilated or just died trying day 472
and 473 was a year and some change into
the family's comfortable existence on
the farm and confinement this is the
majority of the first movie they're
fighting their creatures on the property
and Lee dies day 474 brings us into the
second movie which picks up right after
the events of the first movie they're
leaving the farm the movie really covers
the remaining 475 47 6 and day 477 we
jumped to the infamous New York City
skyline back to the trailer a nice shot
of the Empire State Building and it
looks like the sun's Rising on New York
I'm only noting this because we don't
know what the time of day or season the
aliens actually landed on we think it's
spring because of the baseball game in
the second movie they shot this scene in
June of 2023 so I think it's intentional
that Sam is bundled up right now Sam's
walking in New York and for the most
part it's a normal day everyone's
cruising all honks no banter which is
very important this franchise depends on
literal silence there's a joke people
use online the one that's like the
silence is deafening that's what we want
from this movie I want to hear every
step from Foley the Ambiance the subtle
hints of nature everything because we're
spotlighting the silence she looks up to
the sounds from above and we see balls
of light beaming across an empty Sky a
lone scream little faint Whispers And
what looks like the Stars Are Falling
during the day then a massive ball of
light flies over our screen into the
ground shattering the pavement and we're
back to black like Godzilla minus one we
open to the debris all over the place
people scattered and one woman
illuminated amongst the destruction
easily one of my favorite contrast shots
like the village in the dark disaster
there's our leading Ray of Light which
is Sam the impact has caused her and our
hearing to Cave so we're hearing the
sound of an electric buzz like we have
tontis our ears are clearly ruptured
also these aliens give zero they're
yanking people left and right also I get
it you're scared this man grabs Sam
under the car and begs for help but like
what is she going to do tell him to quit
like you guys she's looking for her cat
I think about this all the time
something like a zombie outbreak Alien
Invasion something wild happening it
would just be me and my cat against the
world she would be a pain in the ass
100% but she doesn't talk so you know we
good she eats before me we twins up in
here I don't have a ton of time to sleep
so I have to make sure when I do I lay
down I'm getting the best sleep possible
which is why I'm so thrilled that this
video is being sponsored by beam's dream
powder dream powder is a super tasty
nighttime cocoa available with or
without CBD ooh dream comes in a variety
of truly delicious flavors like cinnamon
cocoa chocolate peanut butter and sea
salt caramel just to name a few I've
been in a cinnamon Coco movie lately and
it's nicely
spiced it helps me fall asleep faster
and I wake up feeling more alert and
better rested all dream powder is
gluten-free keto free non-GMO keto
friendly vegan and so good one serving
of dream powder has no added sugar is
only 15 calories and depending on what
version you get also contains
ingredients such as melatonin magnesium
and reishi extract to help you fall
asleep and get the most restful sleep
possible I love that dream has a
highquality sleep ingredient that leave
me with zero grogginess the next day in
a clinical study 93% of participants
reported dream helped them get a better
night's sleep and woke up feeling more
refreshed go to shop beam.com neww
rockstars and use code rockstars to get
up to 35% off don't miss out on this
limited time offer then we cut to Joseph
Quinn the man who stole our hearts as
Eddie mson and stranger things he plays
a man named Eric he looks like he's in a
suit and will be the complete opposite
of Sam's character I think if we learn
anything from Barbarian 10 Cloverfield
lane or it comes at night honestly most
horror movies that involve a crisis and
strangers having to be in forced
proximity it never ends well for someone
the last films followed a family this is
following strangers they don't have the
same connection or expectation to defend
each other I like these types of movies
because they stress me out and challenge
all of our morals immediately the
internet also picked up they were using
the spores track from Alien Covenant
written and performed by Jed celle in
the trailer I think it's used during the
god awful medbay scene from Alien
Covenant I don't like it I don't like
that scene I didn't see any other big
alien Easter eggs but in Alien Covenant
they discovered this planet that
immediately became dangerous when the
aliens started attacking and like this
movie all seemed great on Earth until
the aliens came and started attacking
also I'm excited for Quinn this isn't
new for him as an actor seen as stranger
things is kind of sort of going through
the same pickle what if Eddie died in
stranger things and was just
reincarnated as Eric in this universe
they both are scaredy cats so I think
it's true speaking of cats this
beautiful baby is named froto Eric and I
were talking and yes and of course it is
all one big Lord of the Rings reference
froto left the Shire with Sam I'm on a
journey to destroy the ring at Mount
Doom Accord to Entertainment Weekly Sam
is on a day trip to New York which is
about to become a journey of itself and
her name is Sam she's carrying froto
throughout the trailer y'all remember
Return of the King I can't carry it for
you but I can carry you though it seems
like Eric will also accompany them he
might be the borr and be crazy then
sacrifice himself I'm slowly going off
the scenes where he looks like an
uptight suit and Sam looks chill willing
to protect a cat throughout the entire
movie and before you say that cat will
be screaming at 2: a.m. you know what
you might be right it might because cats
like to do that but also cats are better
than a damn baby I'm just saying having
a baby during all of this is insane Eric
and I got into this during the sneak
peek but you're putting everyone in
danger by getting pregnant and I just
don't know what they were thinking in
the last movies they're in a New York
City subway which normally is the
opposite of quiet but during the murder
of Mayhem it's probably the quietest
place on Earth then we jump to the busy
busy New York streets cars are smoking
buildings are smashed but no one is
running they're walking so I wonder
maybe on like day two three or four they
realize that it's sound and they're
trying to evacuate everyone slowly and
quietly but you know damn well one
person is going to fart and all hell's
going to break loose we cut to the
hospital two nurses run down an empty
hallway but the siren lights above them
are blaring this might be Alex Wolf's
character who we know is in the movie
just not the role yet this sequence is
so eye openening in the trailer in terms
of sound People March through New York
the hospital Sirens Eric screaming while
it pours rain outside a blast of light
that could be from the initial Landing
scene and still no actual sound Eric is
now outside and from behind it looks
like an finished guy scraper building
his tie swung over his shoulder and
between that and the pained expression
of fear on his face I'd argue he's
walking across a high steel beam the
street is empty there's cars all over
the place we see one of the aliens on
top of the car and Eric holding on to
Sam as they run to escape her yellow
jacket isn't dirty as we saw on the
debris scene so this scene is probably
around the subway scene quicker cuts
from what looks like a school bus and
the pressure of impact causes the
windows to explode and Sam is covering
her head another cut of what looks like
a church by the overhanging candle it
chandeliers and the cathedral likee
design yellow jacket is missing this
might be right before after she meets
djon hu's character Sam's hand is
outstretched on the rubble so I assume
someone's dead body is under that debris
and if it's Roto I will pop off I will
freak out if it's a cat no cats are
dying on my watch four military jets
shoot across the gray sky then we see
the falling of what I think is the
Brooklyn Bridge we can assume this is
blown up by those Jets and I believe it
was to stop the creatures from leaving
or Crossing into a Manhattan which would
attract them to the noise so I don't
know if it's actually a good idea at the
end of the day this movie might actually
answer the question how was all the
military just so bad we saw the
newspaper clippings about the military
being defeated and some people were
confused how we couldn't be prepared for
this and honestly simple answer is it
happened very quickly in a lot of horror
movies the military's first instinct
when the outbreak is outbreaking is to
cut off the disease at the limb so
they're probably executing a strategy to
keep them in one place then blow that
place up which is probably this scene in
the trailer Eric and Sam probably found
out about the plan of attack and were
trying to reach the Brooklyn Bridge in
time unfortunately it doesn't look like
that's happening I'm assuming the other
bridges are out of commission or just
destroyed they could go the Mist route
and maybe the military was expecting
this or saw hints of the Thousand little
Fireballs headed our way but couldn't
react quick enough ultimately I think
it's unlikely the military knew it was
aliens that are hyper sensitive to sound
with armor prooof skin about to crash
down they probably expected like little
meteorites next to Sam and Eric is jimon
hu's character who played the man on the
island who appeared in the second movie
he was the man who had that small Colony
on the island and then the creature
showed up and killed him hopefully in
this movie though we learn his name How
He adjusted so quickly his family and
his life before it all then we cut to
Sam with Ash and debris all across her
face she's clearly coming too she awakes
coughing when the man on the island
covers her mouth to shush her he must
have ran into her after this scene
because in the background we see the
theater they're currently hiding in he
must have snatched her and dove into the
theater Lobby to hide but it's very
important to acknowledge right here how
quick of a learner he was at the very
beginning then we cut to Eric and Lupita
she's in the yellow jacket here as the
building's glass all begins to fall with
the creatures crawling like spiders down
it God I I hate it I don't like bugs
this is probably part of this scene
they're running from the creatures and
Sam is holding for dear life onto her
cat the end of the trailer gives us a
number to text and I rightfully did so
you guys didn't have to and I got a
creepy text that said sh stay quiet stay
alive so I'm in it for life now I guess
I might die this movie looks so fun it
looks like War of the world's
Cloverfield and Godzilla like I just
love this franchise so much there's so
much room and time to make spin-offs for
this world give me day 55 give me my
birthday what happened in Los Angeles
how did we handle it the trailer is
clearly more chaos than order so there
are still a lot of questions a lot of
military mistakes and timeline
suggestions this movie drops June 28th
and I will be sat let me know if you're
going to go see it and follow me on
Twitter and Instagram at Lulu Clemens
follow new rockstars And subscribe to
new rockstars for more analysis of
everything you love check out the Breck
room and the Deep dive sh be quiet stay
alive